okay so this is burning low none of the
questions from the last episode are
answered like at all
like it doesn't even look like you also
to be continued I was trying to think
that brie may have been right no no no
she's not right we're just gonna go
about then we're gonna assume that it's
gonna come back in another episode like
they usually do it it's okay to be
contigo be continued 20 or 30 episodes
from now you know it can happen did they
bring up things or like at some point in
an episode and they kind of come back to
it like years later okay okay so I'm
looking for I'm still hung out that the
theories we had about it alright so
we'll see how that turns out but until
then we have a burning low this is an
episode you got the return of was a fire
princess relate explain princess comes
back and and they're doing more the
relationship with her and Finn which is
nice it's really nice to see you know
nice to see him like happy with a
girlfriend what's in her being happy
women too
the only problem is every time she
touches him she burns and that hurts and
horribly and probably needs a lot of
stuff yeah so I I'm good no way I'm not
gonna do that
yeah your caffeine your food no matter
to listen to their food they'll sniff it
and then I'll just walk away oh okay
marriage was awesome that way it still
whore in the camera like even the last
one we're doing it's like going around
its what you're gonna notice me you're
gonna do me you were so distracted
she's freaking adorable okay how can I
not be distracted by the adorableness
because we just saw a good episode
that's true let's talk about this girl
episode stop hitting the tin foil
meratol dammit I am trying to talk about
this episode so but people's discovers
the problems she discovers that if they
fall in love
that'll make her unbelievably unstable
the the flame party away unstable and
she'll melt through the Earth's crust
into its core and wells it bounced back
and forth until she disabled eise's yes
okay so kills everything yeah
so be bad uh so but jake has at your he
might be one of my that just maybe
laughed so hard he he goes to sleep at
he said train just goes oh where am i
these little character Cisco hey Jake
you're president now he just goes
alright they just heard dance it's like
that's it it just really made me laugh
oh so I'm very sick silly to bring that
out wasn't that was my mistake my salute
to it so so Jake totally this is the
reason why in mistakes it for people's
being jealous which leads to a not love
triangle sort of and it's it's kind of
funny it's kind of emotional it's like
it it's okay because it leads up to I
think a genuinely nice ending where Finn
and her kiss and she does fall like to
the middle of the world or whatever
thing goes after her and I bet what he
kisses her again and that sort of
rejuvenates the flame was that and holla
yeah because uh Jake was like oh that's
good because if you like keep it plugged
up in a sense she'll go out like her
flame will actually go out which would
be beneficial and then when he kisses a
service or a brought it back yeah but
that kind of again stabilizing yeah
which Ella it's a very you know it's
this very sort of large-scale little
romance going up that's a large-scale
little romance but it kind of is because
it's all he has to do is you know it
serve kiss or be with her but she's
still this burning flaming thing it's
burning his lip and it's hurting him and
he's trying to hold her close but he's
getting more and more burned and it's I
like this stuff I like that when they
set this up that they have a romance but
they quite literally will hurt each
other if they touch each other
I like their serve going in the
direction you want them to go it's like
wow this can make some really large
imagery and some epic situations and
they're taking advantage of that and
they they bring her back up and they're
okay and Jake still thinks Beals is
jealous I think I do love that face oh
so it was genuinely pretty emotional
this but I don't really like love
triangles but this wasn't really bad as
more sort of Finn
coming to grips with his emotion which
actually that's the one thing I loved
about this episode the most was when
people shows up while he's trying to
write the poem and he just unloads on
her not realizing you know she's trying
to be you know serious and try to say
this is what's you know she thinks he
knows what's going on and he unloads on
her and finally admits to her how long
he's been in love with her and he's
finally over her and it's like that's
probably something that he always needed
to voice his feelings and then to
finally say out loud I'm done with you
I'm over I'm moving on even it isn't a
very mean way you know but he thinks
she's being me and then stuff and yeah
if she really was doing that she would
kind of have this coming but it's a
misunderstood something it's a justified
him being mean and him being pissed off
yeah but he doesn't realize that that's
not where she's coming from but it sure
seems like it
right yeah well and the nice thing too
is what do you put in Turpan huh does
mean he's just like oh actually whenever
she shows up yeah I was gonna say bad do
that that that yell that the kid white
bin does is so great whenever she shows
up he just lets out says
yeah I can't duplicate but it's very
very funny um yeah so so a lot of good
uh I love it when she explains to Jake
what's going on it says take me to him
and he grabs her he gets big and his
head just boom nice the wall it's just
there's this i man I just is that about
weeks as I watches I just always forget
how much wonderful energy is in this and
you know even weights just making
pancakes he sinks this little sign you
can pancake they are just so into it um
and they put so much of that energy in
there it's just always so it's just such
a good feeling seeing this show like
returning to this energy you know
especially I don't know how whatever
world's doing but we have really shitty
winter and all sorts of stuff got
delayed because of it and stuff and it's
like when you have a winter that's just
like this top and you have to stay
inside and it's cold and some pain and
stuff like that it's just nice to have
some that can still energize you and
have this kind of energy are you saying
we didn't have a bad winter what is
wrong with you was well like the worst
winter we had in a hundred years a
hundred year might but but actually I
think it's like a hundred years I think
you know like the past few years are a
few years ago when we had the snowplows
where the snow was so high it was taller
than most people that that was this year
no wasn't that's this year - it's not
the one there was a few years ago okay
the reason hold though - hey I don't got
quite that guy it was okay just for that
I'm not gonna point out how you were
unbelievably wrong about people's old I
feel totally reasonable why do you think
I'm not on screen I'm gonna go on camera
and say as a rock I'm gonna wait until
the next episode when I just leave her
again she literally said the end the
episode she's like damn it like people's
was totally responsible she was terrible
alright so she didn't say that I guess
so
no it's a it's a good episode I do want
to bring up something about people so
what's that it's interesting and I'm
very curious about it if it's ever
brought up again because I don't know if
it is what's that she had Flame Princess
locked up yeah I'll sort of wandering it
out like to know backstory so many
people's was causing problems
maybe I'm just defending my wife blind
link but no it is specifically said that
she had her father law and prison her
but I mean it's we kind of we know why
at the same time she doesn't send her
back yeah exactly
so she's literally raising her hand
Oh actually you bring up a good point
that just hit me right now okay so she
had on film oh no it just hit me now so
don't eat my pizza she says that she has
her dad lock her up and this isn't
actually an attack on people's it's like
a continuity question but then if she
has her dad lock her up because god
forbid she falls in love and she
destroys the earth why then was when
Jake going over there to get a new girl
for Finn why was the dad totally okay
with marrying off his daughter maybe he
just wanted to get her out okay well
maybe he's a better dad than we thought
yeah and it wasn't he wasn't in a rush
to get rid of Flame Princess remember
he's like nope you're not good enough
plus it also could be more along the
lines of Finn is good so that kind of
connects a different type of flame and
romance than an evil person would
remember flame King basically said oh
you killed off you're terrible person
okay you're good enough to have her now
while wasting that Finn is cruel and
evil so therefore it's a different type
of flame perhaps or a different kind of
burn than if it was like a pure because
you got to think there's tainted tainted
fire in a sense and then there's purify
them which one's stronger the pure fire
well the other thing too could be that
he wants some what's so big and terrible
is that maybe to keep her in line from
destroying the work well that's kind of
what I'm saying he would kind of like if
it was evil would be like a stifling
thing for her she would never truly be
happy oh she would never be in love oh
yeah
if she gets with someone who's cruel she
seems to not be cruel she seems to be
incredibly innocent she certainly
remembers he was like you know I just
burned like half the people in the room
but what did she destroy a like a whole
town too and stuff you didn't know
remember we've already we've already
been
over this once she gets out she's like
oh and she's like looking at the flowers
not realizing what she's gonna do then
she gets hurt and the only way she knows
how to react is like she's like this
would be my new home this will be my new
Kingham yeah but that she knows there's
people living there but no one could
hurt you still burn and um and stuff
well no she's nice now but it's the only
when she was let out of that cage she
was still pretty it's not like it pissed
it's not like years have passed it's
been weeks yeah you do know a little
older granted he's obviously going
through puberty in his voice but there's
no little timestamp this isn't Downton
Abbey god I watch Downton Abbey there I
said it
yeah I'm done with that hey don't leave
me any note how that feel is greater
than it to me and the whitest thing
you'll ever see in your life will make
you happy if you explain it to me Lane
put it this way it makes Maggie Smith
hip who's Maggie Smith the old nod from
Sister Act
that's how white it is
okay so this is this video is gonna go
up after we review the April Fool's
episode my low point but while we're
getting the episode my low point okay so
we're we're typing it in and I might
look like friendship is magic okay but
when we just typed in my okay and what
comes up to my love my friendship is
magic my nigga rich homie Quan fit young
jeezy and eat white tonight next up my
little pony what the hell that's the
first thing that could pop up this what
you normally watch oh yeah all the time
it's not even alphabetical so just
parents warning if you're looking up My
Little Pony Friendship is Magic II get
to the my part and just quickly scroll
to the right don't